to tell us how an inquiry is going to be
conducted
on our deployment to kabul to helmand
and later the withdrawal
well thank you very much uh mr tugan
heart and
uh of course the uh people
of afghanistan have been
the beneficiaries of as you know decades
of uk
support and investment we've done our
level best to
help the stability the security uh the
peace of that country you yourself
tom have served there uh and it has been
uh a huge huge commitment hundreds of
uh british troops have died
in that cause and if you ask me whether
i
i feel happy about the current
uh situation in afghanistan of course i
i don't i am i'm apprehensive
i think that uh the situation is fought
with
risks we must hope that uh the
uh the parties in kabul can uh can
come together to to reach an agreement
uh and somehow or other we must hope
that
an accommodation must be must be found
eventually uh with the taliban that we
have to be absolutely realistic about
the situation
that we're in and what we have to hope
is that
the blood and treasure spent by this
country over decades in
protecting the people of afghanistan
has not been in vain and that the legacy
of their efforts is protected and that's
what this government will in
will try to do as far as we possibly can
with our american
with our american friends the situation
is difficult i will be making a
statement
uh tomorrow uh on it tom i think
probably it'd be better
not to anticipate any further uh the
statement i'll make
and on the matter of the matter of the
inquiry that that's that that the or
you're ahead of the uh you're ahead of
us there
i think it's um
those servicemen and women uh who lost
their colleagues and their families
will want to know that lessons have been
learned or lessons are being learned and
implemented
how will we make sure that that happens
well we learn
lessons the whole time but if you're if
you're asking me to
extemporize an announcement now about
okay inquiry into
waiting for afghanistan i'm not going to
to do that but
and i don't think that the speaker would
want me uh
to to uh anticipate the statement that i
intend to intend to make uh tomorrow and
i know
tom that you'll be wanting to uh to
interrogate me and then i think that
would be probably the right time can i
just ask
a very quick supplementary about uh
members of the armed forces going on
operations now most of our nato allies
are double jabbing
their personnel before they go on
operations they're not relying on their
civilian rollout in order to make sure
that their
servicemen and women are vaccinated is
this something that you could
at least take away and address
to the best of my knowledge we do have a
for instance or the carrier strike group
that we've
uh just sent out uh around the world
we'll be mixing with
doing operations uh with 40 friendly
countries 40 allies of us
around the world they have protection
from
from the virus thank you
um like we'll crack on short questions
and short answers and we'll
get through all the all the stuff we
want chris bryant
thank you prime minister in the general
election you told miners in mansfield we
will make sure no miner signed up to the
mineworkers pension scheme is out of
pocket
we will make sure that all their cash is
fully protected and returned i have
looked into it and we will ensure that's
done
when is this pledge categorical pledge
going to be honoured
thanks uh uh mr brown um the
the the mine workers uh pension scheme
members are receiving payments that are
higher than they would have been thanks
to uh the government's uh
guarantee and on most occasions the
scheme
has been in surplus but we remain
resolutely committed to protecting the
pensions of mine workers and supporting
their families no but you guaranteed
that the additional money was going to
go to them and you're going to sort out
the issue which
all mps of all political parties on the
bay select
committee agreed to a report which said
that
one the 1.2 billion pounds in the
investment reserve fund which was put in
there by miners
should go to miners and their widows now
not
to the government will you undertake to
honour that pledge
well uh as i as i told as i told you
uh the trustees do have freedom to be uh
less risk-averse with their
investment strategy and i will certainly
uh come back to you on the point that
you raised
the government's already told the bay
select committee that you're not going
to want that pledge so
so do you not know the facts of this
well i'm i'm telling you that uh the
the the mine workers pension scheme
already uh ensures that members receive
payments
higher than they would have done thanks
to the government's guarantee
and we will continue to ensure that uh
the scheme members are looked after
i think a lot of people will be upset
but anyway do you
on that if possible because i don't
think that's really been answered
i'll be more than happy to write thank
you so much
different matter um do you support
closing the loophole so that mps who are
suspended from the house for more than
10 days for sexual harassment and
bullying
are subject to the recall of mp's act i
i know that work is going on to
address this matter and i certainly this
is a matter for the
house and i would urge the house to get
on and do it
it can only be a matter for the house if
the government tables the motion
and supports it will you support it well
i think it's i think that
uh the leader of the house is currently
at work on uh on
a way of closing the loophole and i
certainly urge the uh
mps to get on and do that so you think
that loophole should be closed
i i i there is clearly a loophole and i
see no reason why it shouldn't be closed
but that that is not a matter of the
government that's a matter of a bond
it can only be decided by parliament if
government allows time for it but i i i
take the point that you you do support
that
and at the moment we have four different
registers for ministers and mps to
um abide by the register of ministers
interests the list of ministers
hospitality the list of ministers gifts
and the commons register of members
interests
they all publish these at different
times at intermittent periods in
different places
and according to different rules isn't
it time we had a
sim a single set of rules governing all
of these matters
well some matters are clearly a matter
for
for parliament and uh concern the
the actions of mps and it wouldn't be
would be right for the for the executive
government to
determine how those uh how those work uh
matters relating to the conduct of
ministers uh
are a matter of for the executive and
and i think that's a that's quite a
sensible
uh division but it ends up meaning that
two
members of parliament sitting next to
each other in the royal box of wimbledon
for instance
register the mata in completely
different ways into completely different
rules and a completely different times
and in different places
that just isn't fair is it i think it's
sensible that there should be a
distinction between the invigilation of
the
uh of parliament and of the executive
and
uh it's it's it's not surprising that
there are
there are there are different approaches
and different ways of doing this
the list of ministerial interests is
only published twice a year whereas the
list of members interest is published
much more frequently
by the time the list of ministerial
interests appears
lots of the interests that were relevant
at one point during that time
are no longer no longer appear on the in
the list at all because they are
apparently deemed no longer to be
relevant
wouldn't it make much more sense to
publish the list of ministerial
interests
every month well it's a good it's it's a
it's certainly an idea
uh mr bryant i'm happy to to look into
it but
uh the the system at the moment is that
uh mps and and ministers uh have to
publish
their interests the public can
scrutinize them and and that's
entirely as it as it should be and and i
would encourage everybody to
uh to to do that fit in their uh their
mp's interests uh in a timely way in the
as well as their ministerial interests
but for the most of the last year the
list of ministerial interests hasn't
even been an accurate list of ministers
because it's updated so rarely that it
simply isn't
no member of the public can spot in real
time what are the interests that might
be affecting a ministerial decision
the list of ministerial interests to the
best of my knowledge has only recently
been uh published it's there for your
interest and for the public's uh uh
information
uh people can uh can look at it uh and
and draw the all the conclusions they
need to draw i'm glad i'm glad you
referred to it the latest list says
that there were interests did arise
in relation to the refurbishment of your
flat in downey street
as set out of paragraph 32 of the
independent advisors annual report
paragraph 32 then says an interested
rise but does not say what that interest
was because it says
that by the time of publication which
was delayed by many many months
um this was no longer relevant so can
you tell us what was the interest that
you should have declared
how much was it when was it paid off and
why was it not registered in the
parliamentary register
of members interests for the very good
reason that
there is a ministerial register and
all that needed to be registered as was
duty registered as the advisor on
uh ministerial interests uh little
geitas
as confirmed that's not actually what he
says
and he he produces an entirely circular
argument between paragraph 32
of one report and another paragraph in
another report neither of which reveals
what the
both of which say that there was an
interest that should have been declared
and it has not now been declared i i've
nothing to add to what i've just said
and uh lord guyt has said that
everything that should have been
uh registered has been registered in in
the proper way
final question okay final question from
me
and when a minister
lies
they should correct the record and
presume you agree
of course they might do so inadvertently
that's the general assumption of how we
do our business in parliament that no
minister deliberately lies though there
have been occasions in our history when
that has happened and the minister has
been
forced to resign it seems that you very
rarely
correct the record why is that
i think i think i'm going to need you to
give me a chat and verse there
as they say i think there are plenty of
instances where where
um the the you have been
told by um various independent and
outside bodies that
the the precise words that you've used
have not
been the full um and accurate version of
events well let me give you a question
okay
let me give you an example uh
because and i think you're if i may say
so and great respect to you
uh i'm not entirely sure that uh mr
brown's questions uh
uh are in order but let me give you an
example it's commonly asserted for
instance
uh that when uh we put uh the figure of
350 million pounds a week
uh on the side of a bus uh that went
around this country causing a great deal
of
uh of hoo-ha uh that that was erroneous
and that it would that did not reflect
the true figure it's probably one of the
things that you're thinking of is it mr
brown no no i'm thinking
did you sack matt hancock well let me
let me let me continue at this point uh
did you sat in that anchor
let me give you an example uh of the 300
millibands a week
this was a um a figure that related to
the
gross sum that the uk
gave to the eu budget it was another
subject of lively controversy during the
referendum campaign five years ago as
you remember
uh actually it turned out if anything uh
suburb to be a slight underestimate and
by uh
this year the the gross figure
on your question about mr hancock the
former health secretary
let me just go back to what i said uh
many many times and
i think i said on the floor of the house
of commons uh which was that
we read about you read about we all read
about
the story concerning mr hancock and
uh and and the cctv and so forth
on i think the friday and we had a new
health secretary
on the saturday and considering that we
are in the middle of a
global pandemic and it's quite a thing
to move your health secretary
uh mr bryant i think that was quite fast
going if i may say so that's
all i have to say on that matter that
you said
i'm glad you've had your time i'm sorry
thank you very much
um moving on philip down thank you
prime minister i'm going to move on to
the subject of cop 26 and the
government's
policies and delivery against his
policies on climate change
before i came into this place my mantra
was that past performance
was no guide to the future when the
government
responded to the climate changes could
climate change committee's progress
report recently
the government pointed to the historic
success
uh which is laudable in reducing
reliance on renewable
energy given the covet crisis
uh delay on introducing the
myriad policies required to deliver
against the admirable target of 78
uh reduction in emissions by 1990 when
can we expect
uh you or your ministers to start
delivering
to this house uh the policies that are
required to
to get us to 78 percent well thanks very
much mr donald
you will have seen uh what the
government announced in uh the ten point
plan that i
i set out last november and
you will have seen what is happening uh
with investments
uh in green technology in this country
just in the last week
you've seen nissan confirming in
sunderland
that they're going to be launching a
massive investment in green
vehicles in battery powered vehicles
you saw what's happening with the uh the
gigafactory you've seen what stellantis
is doing at ellsmere port uh in terms of
uh of delivery of
on on wind power and our objective of
becoming uh the saudi arabia of wind
uh there are very there are huge uh
investments going on now
and uh the secretary of state for for
bays
uh as a mandate to produce 40 gigawatts
of wind
uh which is enough uh to supply the
domestic
needs the energy needs of every single
household
uh in this country uh by 2030. that is
an incredible
ambition but i'm sure that we can uh we
can do it
because you i you know you you've been
out to uh
to the coast of uh the northeast around
the country you can see
uh the incredible potential of the uk
you can see what we could do
uh in uh in dogoland uh and elsewhere
uh and uh we will we will do it but and
and we
and you know you you make the point
about the historic
achievement and it is absolutely
enormous
uh don't don't forget that uh i think
that the uk has cut
uh co2 emissions by more than 40 percent
on 1990 levels while uh the
economy has grown uh by 75 percent and
we're confident
uh that green technology and green
investments
are the root not just a cutting co2
but to long-term job creation and
economic growth
i think you're right prime minister that
there is enormous potential for the
private sector to work with government
in investing in new technologies but
they cannot do so in the absence
of clarity about what the government's
demand signals will be
and what strategies will be in place so
wherever you look whether it's the
hydrogen strategy the heat and building
strategy
understanding how we're going to cope
with the energy efficiency
of homes which is a massive task 19
million homes need retrofitting
at the moment there is a vacuna we don't
have these policies
out there the private sector are not yet
in a position
to uh to invest did you see a vicuna i
i i love kunai i tried to say a vikuner
is a
there's a game
and we want to eradicate the lacuna if i
may say
uh the bikuna forms a key part of our
biodiversity objectives
uh but the lacuna is the thing that we
are going to back to the parking lot
but i'm i'm i'm grateful um
uh there is a huge there is a huge
opportunity
uh for this country to to lead in
uh low-carbon technology but also to to
drive
jobs and and growth and
that is what we are uh that is what we
are doing
and uh if you look at what we we've done
since
uh this new government since i came in
two years ago
uh the the ten point plan and you say we
haven't set out the framework for it we
have set out the framework it's there
people can see what we need to do so
it's
it's green vehicles uh and and that's a
big thing in itself and
uh that means uh basically electrifying
our feet and you could not have a more
powerful signal on vehicles
than what the government said we're
moving uh to green
uh to electric vehicles by 2030 in this
country how is
the government setting them the signal
and making the market there's no other
country in europe
that has adopted such a brave and bold
timetable
and what has happened much to our uh
satisfaction
and relief is that the automotive sector
in the in the uk and around the world
has responded and they are investing
and you and i get back to what i said
about the
the nissan investments what's happening
at stellantis and
uh and elsewhere and we will work uh to
ensure
that uh we uh bring the the this is the
key thing
uh to we have the scale of manufacture
in this country uh to allow the price of
these evs
uh and other uh green technology goods
to come down so that's evs
then there's domestic heating so i've
got 30 seconds left
okay let's
uh the cop 26 this is your opportunity
to
be on the world stage with
representatives of every nation on earth
you won't get such an opportunity
during your prime ministership you need
to be able to demonstrate that the uk
is leading as you've just done on
batteries but all the other areas which
where the strategies are not in place
are we going to see these coming out
before cop 26
let's take hydrogen strategy for example
many other countries or 16 other
countries have developed a hydro
strategy we don't have one
i'm afraid i've got to to disagree with
you uh completely that the uk is
the uk was the first country in the
world that it
uh its first major developed economy uh
to set
a a net zero target by 2050 when
this government took over the running of
cobb this
government took over the running of cop
only 30 of the global economy was
committed
uh to uh net zero by 2050 it's now
70 and we have a huge on hydrogen uh
it's
it's there in the ten point plan bays
are driving
a a very strong hydrogen strategy and
they haven't published it
and that's the point and if you look at
what's happening with carbon capture
and storage in the creation of hydrogen
green hydrogen
uh blue hydrogen uh in the northeast and
elsewhere i think you're right i think
hydrogen is a big part
but they have a public strategy but it
is it is only one of the
uh of the of the horses that were
betting on it it must be a beast
i have a question for the final question
which i think we can agree
you i believe were as shocked as i was
to see uh reports
of amazon destroying unsold consumer
electronics
from a warehouse less than an hour away
from glasgow will you be holding cop26
is there anything that you can do as a
uk government to hold
global corporates to account for their
environmental footprint
i i read that and i was absolutely
horrified though i noticed that amazon
then tried to
uh clear it up in some way and claim
that it wasn't as it had been
initially uh presented i don't know the
the reality of the
of the position by obviously destroying
uh consumer electronics in the to
landfill and that was absolutely
insane but what we have done and this we
did this at the g7
uh we for the first time got global
agreement
uh that that there should be a tax on
the sales
of uh internet giants such as amazon
on the basis of the the sales in market
so in the uk there's a massive
achievement
uh led i may say by rishi uh by the by
the chancellor
uh to get a global agreement on on
taxing
uh the internet giants and and about
time too
thank you mr dun clive betts thank
uh to continue with the theme of moving
towards zero
carbon uh looking at the situation in
housing now
um housing is responsible for about
fifteen percent
fifteen one five percent uh of carbon
emissions the
uh commission uh climate change
commission said in december
uh that there have been minimal progress
in recent years
uh in reducing the level of emissions
from housing
and what we need and we're coming back
to the point from before was an
agreement framework not on a green
framework about what we want to achieve
but how we're going to achieve it
where can i find that framework it's
showing how we're going to get to zero
uh net zero carbon in housing well first
of all i'm
clive i'm going to disagree with you
tentatively timidly about
uh what's happened already uh because
there's been a massive reduction in
emissions from
uh housing and it's been if you look at
the look at the proportion of emissions
now that come from
from transport that's because we forced
down uh emissions co2 emissions
uh from uh from uh domestic uh heating
and uh and also commercial property
now now the big chance is and let me
just give you one statistic
uh 40 of homes uh in england that's 10.8
million homes are now above uh energy
performance certificate
uh band c that's up from only 12
uh in 2009 which was about yeah but what
the commission said the prime minister
was there had been reasonable progress
up to 2015
the last five years there's been minimal
progress that's in the commission's
report
well the the what i'm saying is there is
massive progress that
has been made and not just recent years
and continues
to be made so what we're what we're
doing now and this is
and i'm going to be frank with the
committee this is something that is very
difficult to pull off
because what we need to do is to ensure
uh that we're able to
heat people and homes and provide them
with power
in an affordable way whilst also
reducing
co2 and you know perfectly you know
perfectly well mr betts
that the ways of doing that
through ground source heat pumps or air
source heat pumps all through hydrogen
as
as philip was saying these are these are
the principal alternatives
uh that we have and what we're doing is
building
a market uh working with the with
producers
with manufacturers with the whole sector
to ensure that as we as
just as we're doing that with uh with
the electric
vehicle manufacturers we drive the bills
right down
okay we can't have what we can't have is
a situation
in which uh ordinary uh homeowners
ordinary people
living in that in in their own home are
suddenly faced with an unexpected
uh and unreasonable cost to put in
private sources
i'll tell you climate change commission
said and i think on the path to net zero
we have to get all homes not using
fossil fuel boilers
by 2033. that's 25 million homes
last year they were 38 000
heat pumps put in in homes 38 000 and we
provide
2033 all homes have got to have a heat
pump
or a hydrogen boilers which aren't
currently yet available where is the
plan to do that
you're right but they're what we're
doing is working
with the uh manufacturers and working
with the market so it can be done to
ensure that we
have the uh the heat pumps in sufficient
quantity to bring
uh the price down at the moment let's be
frank these things cost about 10 grand
at a pop
okay uh this is this is a lot of money
uh we
for ordinary people we've got to make
sure that these are that when we when we
embark on this program
that we have a solution that is
affordable right and that works for
people and
we won't do it uh we won't be imposing
it until we
right so it's a 2033 target that
was going to be delivered i think we can
do it in a very rapid time scale
and that's what we are doing but it
takes a great deal of uh determination
it means
uh working with the uh the producers it
means driving down the cost
it means as i was saying to philip about
electric vehicles it means
setting the market and setting the
parameters at the moment at the moment
the prices are too high right can i just
talk then about
future planning because one organization
looking at planning is an organization
called place shapers now they're they
an organizations
they they they have about a million
homes uh their responsibility a million
homes
they've looked at what it would cost
them a part of their business plan to
get to zero carbon homes by 2050
for a million homes they calculated it
was going to be 104
billion pounds only one of them could do
it without going bankrupt
so where is the financial plan to enable
social housing providers who want to do
the right thing to be able to plan ahead
and do it i think you're in a way you're
repeating what i've just said which is
that
where is the cloud well the the plat the
the plan
is to work with the manufacturers of
these yeah
what is the financial plan and to afford
it
and we will be bringing forward a plan
undercover budget
where's that under carbon budget we will
be bringing forward a plan
before cop uh 24.
uh this year before cop you'll be
getting a plan on
the decarbonization of the domestic
market in this country but what i'm
saying to you
and i think people will be interested in
this uh this government is determined
to keep bills low absolutely and to make
sure and
that is and that is a priority now the
only way to to do that
is to build the market in a very
systematic way to make sure that we have
the
the technology and make sure that it's
affordable and there are some big bets
that we
we may need to place uh some bets we may
need to place
on hydrogen uh but also some bets on
that uh on ground source and air source
heat pumps and that that will have a
plan where government shows
their financial support but for social
housing and for only occupiers who want
to do the right thing yes
and there are the the models and the
solutions
uh may be very different uh across
different
uh types of uh housing uh different
uh variety different housing stocks uh
you know all the arguments we'll be
a long before uh before cop 26.
good we look forward to it moving on to
caroline notes
thanks bernard are you hoping for any
gender-specific
outcomes from cop 26 and if so how will
they be measured
thanks very much caroline i think that
the
cop 26
program is one that will be of immense
benefit to all of humanity
but i believe that in helping to tackle
a climate change and it will help to
tackle economic inequality and
i i think that it will inevitably
be of massive benefit to those who have
tended
to suffer the most uh women in
particular who
uh and who don't get uh
when it comes to their education for
instance caroline
don't get in in my view as much
investment as they need and one of the
things that we did at the g7
uh was to ensure that we put another
two and a half billion into the global
partnership for education
the bulk of which is to be spent on
female education around the world
uh that's something i campaigned on for
a for a very long time
and i think that everybody coming to cop
26 uh will understand that there's a
there's a there's a there's a clear link
between
economic progress uh sorting out uh
climate change
addressing climate change and empowering
and advancing women and ending the
injustice
that
so many young girls around the world
receive far less
investment in their education than
young boys of the same age
will the cuts to uk aid help those girls
prime minister
the uk is actually investing more
putting more money into
education female education i think we're
putting uh 453 million pounds
into uh the the global partnership for
education and
uhuru kenyatta of uh of kenya is
is coming to london uh in just a few
days time
to to help us raise even more
thank you moving on tom tugan
thank you at the g7
you didn't manage to get any of our six
closest
allies to pledge to abandon coal use
how do you think you're going to manage
to get china to do something similar
in glasgow china is
a a huge huge global economy a huge
economy the fastest uh growing emitter
and we have to we have to address that
problem and i think that how are you
going to how are you going to get
and i think that what you can't do is
um simply uh push china away
uh say that uh we was having nothing to
do with
uh china uh china is
a member of the of the p5 china sits on
the u.n security council quite rightly
uh we've got to engage with china and
and make the case to china and one of
the
i think one of the most important things
come out of the g7
was the idea of the uh build that better
world
uh the the or the clean green initiative
and that is a that is a way i'm gonna go
go to my questions prime minister robin
your answers if you'll forgive me for a
second that's
your stretch
to my questions not to the questions you
wished i'd asked um
you did say in the general assembly in
2019 that digital authoritarianism is
not alas the stuff of dystopian fantasy
but of emerging reality how is that
compatible
with your recent decision rather your
government's recent decision not to call
in
newport wafer fab uh for investigation
this is a very difficult business and
this is this this relates to people
should know it's relates to a
a chip manufacturer in wales uh
we're we're looking into it the i've
asked the national security adviser to
uh to review uh so it is being reviewed
now
we will look at it again uh but don't
forget that business center told me
thanks to the welsh government thanks to
they they
they rather sweetly asked us to uh to
deal with it
um but uh what i can tell you uh
tom is that thanks to this government
and our prudence in
uh passing the national security and
investment bill which i'm sure you voted
for
i do good uh we we are we are able to
uh to take action well i'm delighted
it's a very important question that you
passed there and therefore if it's not
used
but i want to stress and and on this
issue and
and there will be others uh don't forget
this is the government
when i came in we took the very
difficult and painful step and greg will
know all about this because you were
a business secretary to deal with this
uh we took a very difficult and painful
step of having to disease
extricate this country from what from
the far away i remember
rebellion so so this
government uh is spending a huge
quantity of taxpayers money
uh to make sure that we uh get huawei
out of our
telecommunications uh networks or out of
the critical
uh prime minister you're going over
history man
and but i want to make a very very
important point because uh
we i do not want us and i do not want uh
anti-china spirit to lead to us trying
to pitch fork
away sir bernard every investment
uh from china into this country i have
to say prime minister there is
sorry there is a difficulty if i may
there is a difference between
investment which is looking for a normal
return to the purchase of technology and
what we're seeing here from xperia which
as you know
is a company that is mostly owned
actually by a chinese state bank firm
we're seeing a chinese state-backed
entity
buying a semiconductor manufacturer at a
time of global shortage when beijing is
already looking
for to stockpile semiconductors now if
china thinks this is a matter of their
national security and essential to their
sovereignty
if italy if brussels if the united
states if other countries
agree and other entities agree why don't
you i i think semiconductors are of huge
importance to this country
and one of the things that i i wanted to
look at immediately i became prime
minister
uh was whether or not we could become
more uh self-reliant
and that it i'm told it costs about nine
billion pounds for us to build a
proper semiconductor factory it's it's a
lot of money uh particularly during a
pandemic
you know we're thinking about we're
thinking about what to do there is this
company
uh they make a lot of semiconductors in
ireland as you know
uh but there is this company in in
newport we have to judge
uh whether uh the stuff that they are
making is
uh a you know real uh intellectual
property
uh value of interest to china whether
the real security
uh implications i've asked the national
uh security adviser to
to look at it now you mentioned the
pandemic and you mentioned the pandemic
and i'm delighted you did because
your decision on 0.7 to 0.5 must have
been a very difficult decision for you
if you committed so
publicly and clearly and frequently to
0.7 yourself and i remember as foreign
secretary you did as well
we're seeing a cut in the budget going
to
uh global tropical medicine and global
vaccines at a time when we now know
the interconnectedness of all our health
globally it's going from 150 million
pounds to 17 million pounds at a time
when we're seeing variants coming in
from
well all over the world and are likely
to see more variants
in the near future will you
be making sure that there is a vote in
parliament on this issue
and will you be looking to reverse such
cuts which undermine the national
security of this country
as quickly as possible well again i'm
going to i'm going to disagree
with you in your in your
characterization of what this government
is is doing
uh because actually uh we you talk about
vaccines
uh we put 1.5 billion of uk taxpayers
money
into uh supporting uh the the supporting
kovacs and i think
uh further uh 450 or so and that's
brilliant
and i just remind people uh watching
this that
of the 1.5 billion vaccines that the
world has so far that
the developed nations have so far
distributed around the world
are roughly a third uh as a result
of the efforts of the uk government the
deal we did with
oxford uh so that those vaccines are
distributed at
cost that's the direct result of uk
government action i think people should
be
very very proud of that extremely proud
we're talking about very very big sums
of money uh
in a pandemic when we've had to spend
407 billion pounds
looking after the uh jobs uh livelihoods
uh well-being welfare of families in
this country
as well i think you should be rightly
proud of the vaccines thank you mr
dugan i'm very grateful to you thank you
thank you prime minister you've talked a
good talk about the ambitions you've got
for net zero but
37 billion of revenue a year is solely
dependent on the consumption of fossil
fuel greenhouse gas emissions
37 billion same price as test and trace
just for ease
um and 28 billion is fuel duty alone
so how can you give the british public
an idea of how you're going to fill that
gap in revenue
as we go greener sorry 37 billion
revenue from from fuel
from fuel for 28 billion from fuel due
to 37 billion
which is dependent meg i mean you're
making an incredibly an incredibly uh
good point you're talking about our
fiscal the fiscal impact of moving to
to green technology and and and the the
implications
of of that as you as you phase out
hydrocarbon vehicles you phase out
internal combustion engine
vehicles that you you you phase out we
know why these are public
uh there is a there is a down the line
uh of course the the exchequer will
start to
to see a loss of uh of revenue
what i don't want to do and let it be
said now uh and i saw some
uh some some misreporting about this
what i don't want some misunderstandings
to say i don't want to see uh
fuel bills go up uh to to compensate if
you if you see what i mean meg so
uh that is that is not uh the way
forward
so that's off the table is there
anything on the table well that
that's a matter of further i would not
presume to anticipate uh the
the the fiscal uh options of the of the
chancellor
at a budget or any other uh fiscal event
as you know
well there's something to be said for
encouraging the chance of the exchequer
to make a major statement
how we're going to plan public
expenditure on taxation over the next
decade
i don't think you could you could call
the chancellor for making major
statements uh uh
in the last you'll encourage a few a few
few few months i think he's
i would encourage him to do that i think
you will you'll you'll
you will find that he uh has a lot to
say
uh in due course very good um we're now
going to move on to
kobe's secondary impacts and the kobe
pandemic
um so can i start with greg clark
uh thank you very much indeed sherman
good afternoon prime minister
uh i'd like to ask you about some of the
the lessons
um that can be learned so far in
responding to the pandemic but before i
do can i just ask a couple of
quick questions of current concern and
first is
why shouldn't double vaccinated brits be
able to go on holiday to spain this
summer
thanks greg look i think the double
vaccination is a
a potential and actually it's a great
liberator uh in principle in practice i
think it's going to be it's going to be
great
uh and it already is you know you can
see the benefits to
two vaccines whether of uh pfizer or or
astrazeneca or
or or more people they offer a lot of
protection
and so uh what you will find is if you
if
you can continue your impatience just a
little bit is that the secretary of
state for transport
uh maybe saying more about that uh in
the course of the next few days even
um we know from the press that uh it's
going to be about quarantine but what
i'm interested is your instinct
on the the guidance for ambulance
countries which states
you should not travel to ambulance
countries is your interest to get rid of
it
i i think you should you should i really
don't want to anticipate or to
steal the thunder of the secretary of
state for transport but uh the
what i what i can say is if you repeat
what i've said already i think that
double vaccination offers massive
potential
uh there are the recognize they're going
to get the guidance and the
the requirements they shouldn't they
shouldn't yeah of course okay
and so you'll but you'll you'll see a
lot more on that i think i think
the the the crucial thing is to
um remember that uh currently um
we we need to contain the uh the
pandemic we need to
uh well let's come on one question
before we go into
that double vaccination clearly the way
forward so um the 16th of august
um when contacts of people with covid no
longer have to
isolate is the 16th of august is that
the date
that you expect us to reach herd
immunity in this country that that's not
the the consideration so what's the
significance of the success
it's the time by which we feel that
uh there will have been much more
progress made in
vaccinations more than the 19th uh even
even more than the 19th of july and
all these decisions are a balance of of
risk
and by the by the 16th of august we will
have
got many more jabs into people's arms
many more young and healthy people
many more people vaccinations yeah which
is a good thing because it it but they
are the
the most robust against we're waiting
for sure
and and i you know i'm sorry that
they've had to wait uh and they're
frustrating uh
is it the case that until we get to that
point on the 16th of august
people who have been jab twice uh will
have to isolate
even if they've had a negative covert
test
we're asking people to to i say i know
how frustrating
it is um but
because uh we have to there i'm afraid
the this is a highly
contagious disease and
we have to we have to do what we can to
stop its spread
and uh that's the that's the
aspect of how many contacts will have to
isolate
during that extra 28 days after the uh
the united states well clearly
that that will depend on the uh on the
spread of the people have you seen
i i haven't seen any any any data on
that and
obviously it will depend on uh on the
numbers so the health secretary has said
that there could be around 100 000
infections a day
and if each of those has two contacts
each that's
200 000 a day so over the course of that
28 days the extra days that have been
imposed
that's over 5 million people
is that a reasonable step and have you
considered
how many hospital admissions that is
going to prevent
we've been looking at all the uh the
data and trying to strike the
the right balance and um
so what is what i what about your size
well
the two sides of it are that you could
you could simply say uh we're going to
dispense all together with
uh with self-isolation and move straight
to uh to a testing regime and not bother
uh with asking people to do that anymore
the the difficulty with that
is that you would be effectively
uh allowing many more people to be
vectors of
disease uh than by continuing with our
uh with our plans but do you have an
estimate of how many fewer hospital
admissions would result from that
i can't give you that that number what i
can certainly say
is that uh we believe that the program
of test trace
and isolate has actually made a massive
difference to uh to the disease you know
and
i know that your respects to john bell
the regis professor of medicine
uh at oxford um and he uh in evidence to
my committee he said at the very least
you should be able
to be tested and released from code
rather than
to have to isolate for that period and
what he said was that actually it's
more likely that people will comply uh
with the guidance
if there's a way out of it if they test
negative would you
would you consider at least taking sir
john's very expert advice
we're we're moving to testing that's
that's better
rather than before the that's the
classic question well that's that's
that's the date where
obviously we keep all data under review
we'll always uh
be open to uh you know looking at the
data but that's
we think the sensible approach we want
to we want to retain
uh the uh tool of asking
people uh to protect others
from the disease it's been effective
it's important no matter how many
people and i think we should stick with
it no matter what
let me ask you one um last question um
obviously we're gonna have the public
inquiry that we'll
look back when it's all over but it is
important to learn lessons on the way
and the science and technology committee
and the health and social care
committees
are conducting an inquiry into that
what would you do differently given
experience
and what would you do a second that's a
very big uh question but i think i think
what i could i mean
i can if you ask me uh what um
things that we what things have we
started to do differently and where we
where have we really adapted since
we've learned since the experience
during the week i mean that is a really
good question and
since the beginning of the pandemic what
have we learned that's that
that's obvious i think that to begin
with um
uh it was clear that we didn't have the
all the data that we needed and we
certainly didn't have it all in one
place or
all in all in the right place every
morning now
i i go straight into a meeting where i
can see pretty much what's happening in
any hospital
in the country i can see the breakdown
by
by age by uh by by
variant type i can see exactly what's
happening
in a pretty much real time so we've set
up the uk
uh health security agency uh we we have
a we have a we absolutely brought that
so data we didn't have
and now and now we have i think that
um diagnostics uh it was an obvious
thing we didn't even know how to make a
lateral flow test
uh when we began we did we didn't have
the technology
in this country we now do we we now have
a diagnostics industry that's
uh that's growing um ppe
we you know we remember what how
difficult and traumatic that that was so
these are lessons learned on the way
we we now have the ability to make 80 of
the of our ppe
in in this country um to say nothing of
a vaccine uh technology which is
obviously developed basically i think
the single most important thing i mean i
know how much greg you care about this
and i think you're i think you're right
the single most important thing
uh that we've learned uh certainly that
i've learned
is the overwhelm the massive benefits to
our country
to our society to our economy of
investing in science
and there is you know you could not have
a clearer object lesson
uh than the uh the discovery of the
oxford
vaccine the impact that is now having on
our ability to open up
our society uh in a way that otherwise
frankly
we couldn't well i certainly agree with
that thank you well thank you very much
um we're running over time badly
but uh we will press on as quickly as
possible um mr timms
recommended that the 20 pound a week
universal credit
uplift should be made permanent and last
weekend
all six of the conservative former
secretary of state for working pensions
since 2010 made the same
call how do you respond to that call
i i understand uh very much
why people want to
continue to invest in and to support the
poorest and neediest in this in this
society and that's what we're going to
to do and uh we will
uh continue uh with uh
an increase in uh in pay for the
uh for the lowest paid uh workers
which which we've done uh we're
increasing we've increased the national
uh living wage uh we've uh we've given
councils
uh huge sums to help those in in
greatest
uh need uh i think four million uh
families have been helped to pay their
their council tax bills uh you you refer
to the universal credit uplift amongst
many many other things that we have done
and then and they're huge and they're
part of the 407
billion but i i want to i want to stress
that as we come
to to uh towards the inflection point
uh in this pandemic when uh we we
start to lift the uh non-pharmaceutical
interventions we start to lift the
restraints on
society start to lift the the
government-imposed
dictat that told people they couldn't go
to work
remember what we were saying as we lift
that as we move beyond that
we have to have a different emphasis and
the emphasis has got to be on getting
people into work
and getting people into jobs but do you
think that's what you're ian
admiration for all those people and i i
understand where that where they're
coming from but
the emphasis that this government uh is
placing uh
is on uh coming out of the of the
pandemic
with a strong jobs-led recovery
if the cut goes ahead in three months
time unemployment support will be at its
lowest level in real terms for over
30 years just as the end of the furlough
scheme increases
unemployment according to the joseph
roundtree foundation half a million
people would be pushed below the poverty
line by taking the 20 pounds away
including
200 000 children and the universal
credit allowance for under-25s have
obviously been hard hit by
job losses in the pandemic that'll be
cut by a quarter
can all that damage really be justified
but i i think that the answer to that uh
and i understand what you're saying but
the answer the answer is
is to get people into work if you look
what's actually happening
uh since uh just in the last few months
uh you've seen that unemployment
projections for unemployment which you
rightly worry about but they're two
million
fewer uh than we we were told uh there
were going to be we have lower
unemployment than uh virtually all of
the rest of the
of the g7 vacancy rates are up at uh
pre-crisis levels
uh and and uh the number of people on
the payroll
and i've been rising for the for five
consecutive months it's true
there are now two million people still
on further and you have your right to
to draw attention to that and that's a
very considerable concern
but if you look at what but mr tims if
you look at what's actually happening in
the
the jobs market if you look at what's
happening in the jobs market
the the problem at the moment as i think
uh most colleagues would
testify is uh a shortage of
labor not a shortage of jobs that's what
we
expect that taking the 20 pounds a week
away will cause a lot of
hardship to a large number of people i
think that the best way forward
is to get people into higher wage higher
skilled
jobs and that's the ambition of this
government and we think
and if you if you ask me to make a
choice between more welfare
or better higher paid jobs i'm going to
go for better higher paid jobs well
that's always been the view of ian
douglas smith of course but he's calling
for
the 20th week to be retained will you
review this policy between now and
september
of course we keep everything under under
constant review but i've given you a
pretty clear steer
about what my instincts are and we're
also uh by the way
developing and pushing forward a lot of
really excellent schemes for getting
people into work so
not just kickstart but uh but restart
and uh
and jets uh the job entry training
scheme
to help people into work i think that
should be our mission
that should be our our crusade can i
raise a different point
with you in in february you made the
point to me
in the chamber rightly i think that the
government
is worried about the increase in online
fraud
the working pensions committee the
treasury committee the governor bank of
england
financial conduct authority city of
london police have all called for the
online safety bill
being published now to tackle
scams why is the government unwilling to
make that change to that bill uh i'm i'm
not aware that we're we're failing to do
that but i will
it i'm very uh concerned that we should
uh tackle fraud and indeed i'm told that
the online safety
bill uh online bill does uh just that
and and companies companies
it does it for a very small part of the
problem which is user generated content
it doesn't do it for
online advertising and that seems to be
on a much longer
term track and it's causing huge
problems
so i wonder whether you could just have
a look at the current online safety bill
and see whether it could be changed to
uh tackle online fraud i i i'm told that
the bill will tackle a
a wide range of uh of content and takes
a
a focused approach online for if if you
feel that it's in
uh it's in some uh way inadequate i'm
i'm
more than happy to to look at it but i i
know that the
uh one of the key objectives of the
online safety bill
is to need to tackle uh online i'm
grateful thank you
thank you mr tunes um robert halphon
education um thank you chair um
good afternoon prime minister we've
we've got argentinian levels of
hyperinflation in our schools with 640
000 pupils being sent home this week
compared to 385
000 the week or so before the sense of
social justice have identified 93
500 ghost children who for the most part
have not even returned to school since
they were fully opened on march the 8th
we've also got exam orphans with year 10
pupils due to
gcses next summer missing one in four
days of face-to-face teaching
of course the three billion catch-up
program is hugely welcome but what is
your
long-term plan to address endemic
pupil absence those peoples who have not
even been back to school
and establish a level playing field so
that uh
all students have a fair crack of the
whip doing exams next year
thanks rob but i know how much you you
care about this and how
uh you know the vociferously vehemently
you campaign on
on this on this issue and you're right
and what's what the
what's happened over the last 18 months
has been
uh for many many children uh really
really
uh debilitating there's no there's no
question that they've lost
uh unconscionable amounts of
of teaching and learning time and
we must remediate that we must make it
better uh it's it's
probably the single most important
investment uh that we can make
so in addition to the the 14 billion
that we're putting into
to education that we began with as this
government
uh what we have a catch-up plan uh
for a three billion pound catch-up plan
so far
so far this and before we come to uh any
and anything that the chancellor may do
uh later on this year
and uh what that focuses on you ask how
we're gonna do it
i think the thing that works and the
thing that i find that
uh parents and uh teachers and pupils
respond to
is more uh direct one-to-one uh one to
two
uh tuition uh and actually focusing on
the needs of the
of the individual child and uh
drawing out where that they're going
wrong uh what their
uh what and and really trying to to
focus on that so we've got a massive
program
i get i completely and with you on that
i support the catch-up plan three
billion is a significant sum of money
but
we know that the catch-up program thus
far is just reaching 44
of uh pupils on free school meals surely
it should be focused on the most
disadvantaged
and it doesn't address the endemic
absence the 93
500 children who are barely in not in
school virtually for most of the time
as i said the sense of social justice um
have identified so why not
redirect um the way the catch up program
uh is running and also expand the
troubled families program to try and get
these children back into
back into school rob i think the best
look i know i know how unbelievably
frustrating it is for
uh for parents and for
pupils for at the moment because of the
the numbers that are out of school
because of the
uh the isolation policy that greg and i
were talking about just now
and uh the the the bubbles being uh sent
home and
uh you know uh i i understand why
schools have been taking the actions
that they have they
they want to stop the spread of code and
they're quite right and
and i i fully fully uh support them but
the the best thing
uh is is to move as i think the
secretary of state for education said
uh yesterday uh from bubbling uh to
uh to testing as the answer and as i was
uh saying to
to greg that is that is one thing that
will help us to keep more kids
uh in school um there are others there
are other plenty of other children
uh who are losing uh school time uh
for other reasons as i think you're
you're hinting
uh we need to deal with that in a in a
in a very very determined way and we
need to
uh there will be more that i want to do
on time in school and making sure that
we
uh invest in uh this in the school
timetable as well
so just finally um chad so just to be
clear that you will have a focus on the
closed hundred thousand kids ago i call
them the ghost children not haven't even
been back in school
since uh even when they fully reopened
um in march but
do you not think there should be a
long-term plan for education which
a significant part of it would require
us a longer school day not just for
academic catch up but for
extracurricular activities such as sport
and well-being and what more needs to be
done to convince you
as prime minister and the treasury that
a fully funded long-term plan with a
longer school day
is worth supporting and giving proper
resources to
uh we're doing we're looking at the
evidence and
uh if i'm absolutely frank with you and
the committee
uh to begin with some of the evidence
that was assembled was not as good as it
as it could have been if the evidence on
on on timetable the evidence on
lengthening the school day wasn't as
powerful as it was
on on on on tuition for instance but
that doesn't mean it's not the right
thing to do i do think it's the i do
think it's the right thing to do
uh the question is uh how you do it uh
what sort what sort of activities is it
enrichment is it academic uh what's the
mixture
as you rightly say uh we're doing a
proper review of
all of that as uh to get the the
evidence that we
uh that we want but in the meantime over
the summer
uh there's as you know the the the all
the summer schools
the holiday activities fund uh a big big
effort
to try to help the kids uh kids to catch
up uh before september as well
just will you grab will you look at the
troubled families program to try and
grab these students back into school
that the close 100 000 have not been
in school at all other means to try and
get these kids back into school because
they're not going to be helped by the
catch-up fund as it is
no i understand i've been currently
running no i look you're making a very
good point and
and you know it's that you get into a
risk of a circular problem
you you you you keep missing the same
group uh so i will certainly look at
what we can do
thank you thank you thank you prime
minister could we
um just spare a thought for the teachers
because the health service
gets all the limelight in this pandemic
but the teachers have taken
a hell of a burden and what the teachers
have i've
subverted you're completely right and
the support staff
don't forget yeah
and they and and they've done an
incredible job and what's so interesting
when you go to some you go to some
schools
you can see uh the the challenge that
they have
because some kids some some children
really are incredibly resilient and have
just bounced through it without any
problems at all
uh but that's not the case by any means
for every uh child in this country and
it's had
it's had a big impact on could you ask
your education secretary
to make sure that they get um a break
this summer from initiatives from his
department
which have very often been contradictory
and
had to respond fast-moving pandemic of
course but they long for a period of
stability and predictability and can you
have a word with him and see if he can
provide them with a little bit
i i i will do everything i can to
thank you i totally understand that
point and uh all i would
plead in in
mitigation and forgiveness from uh our
wonderful teachers is it has been
difficult to work out
how to keep some things going how to do
examinations and
uh but you know your point as well mate
thank you catherine mckenna
thank you and could i also add the
challenge that many teachers face
currently which is that they are off
school with covid and that
is causing huge difficulty for schools
and obviously compounding the issues of
catch-up and i
absolutely echo what the select
committee chair has said and wanted to
ask you about that as well on behalf of
petitioners because the education policy
institute calculated the education
catch-up spending
per head in england is around 19
of what the u.s is spending and 12 of
what the netherlands is spending
how do you explain that well i i don't
recognize those because i don't
i don't agree with them because uh they
felt
give you the actual thing they failed to
take account of the uh of the
of the 14 billion that we uh invested in
education as soon as i became
uh prime minister 40.4 billion uh which
took
um funding for every primary school
uh people up to four thousand pounds
ahead funding for every secondary school
people up to
uh five thousand pounds ahead uh so we
we we began with massive investments
and we've added another 3 billion
and there will be more to come so yes
the overall spending on
cat shop for english pupils is 310
pounds per head and in the us it's
sixteen hundred pounds ahead in the
netherlands at two and a half
thousand pounds ahead we know the impact
of this pandemic has been enormous
on children and young people and why is
it that the prime minister feels we
don't need to invest
in helping them catch up and make the
best of going forward in the future
well that's that's obviously not how i
see it where we're
making uh a uh thick end of 20 billion
pound
uh investment already and there will be
more to come
so moving on to the impact of
current covert numbers and also the
potential impact
when the restrictions are released on
the 19th of july
and i know you've said on many occasions
you don't actually have the data
which is quite concerning because the
impacts on current covert levels
particularly in regions like the north
east where we're seeing a surge we're
already seeing businesses
unable to function and hospitality
businesses having to close
and if i take nurseries for example
they have to maintain legal ratios of
staff to children
in order to stay open and the earlier
sector has a very young workforce many
of whom are not
double vaccinated so cases are
skyrocketing
and nurseries are being put in the
position of having to turn families away
in order to maintain
legal ratios which families do you think
they should be prioritizing
well i thank them for all the they're
doing it for the difficulties that
they're
they're going through the as i was
saying to to greg earlier on we have to
make sure
uh that we use the tools we have to
uh in the form of of isolation uh to get
through this particular phase it won't
last long
uh you talk about uh businesses or
hospitality sector businesses closing
actually
uh thanks to the vaccine rollout uh we
were able to get through to
step three uh and and now it looks as
though you know we'll take the final
decision on
july the 12th but it looks as though
we'll get through to to step
four um which will allow them to open up
uh fully
uh without the need for uh for the one
metre rule
and that will you know that's the most
positive thing that can happen
that's all in theory prime minister
because the reality is that
businesses are facing huge staffing
issues with many having to isolate
and therefore not able to function as
businesses it's in the hospitality
industry
it's in many other industries but
particularly in those industries where a
lot of young people are employed
so does the prime minister have the data
for the
relaxations he's proposing and how those
businesses are going to be affected
over the next two to three months given
we're already seeing the impact
of high covert levels in areas like the
north east
yes i mean if i if i may respect it i
don't think
it's possible to uh to argue
simultaneously that
businesses need to uh be able to be more
open and
and and and at the same time to oppose
to oppose the relaxations it's not quite
clear
the problem i had a bit of this earlier
earlier that's not the argument i'm
making
i mean you can't have it both ways uh
you're right you're either in favor of
uh of uh of opening up and uh
i'm asking for the data i'm asking
whether i've already been very clear
that
uh we have data about um
hospitalizations and uh and death we
have data about our
predictions for uh for where
uh they might go uh but you know then
they're available under the spotless by
em uh
mo uh charts you you can look at them uh
but
uh they're speculative at the moment uh
we're tracking in about the middle
of the projections uh that
uh spy m made for uh
the third wave if we went ahead uh with
all the openings so were
were the the middle to uh to low end of
the projection
projections that they made if you if you
look at the graphs
so the current crisis has put many new
parents particularly mothers
at risk of redundancy and so two years
ago the government
announced they would extend redundancy
protection for new mothers returning to
work
to six months that was two years ago
when is this going to happen
we want to help uh new mothers uh
to return to work uh but we want to help
everybody together
when is the redundancy protection going
to happen that's been promised
i can't give you give you the answer to
that particular
uh of that particular payment but what i
can certainly uh
tell you is that at the moment that the
problem is
as i said earlier on the problem is not
so much a
a shortage of jobs or
uh a lack of vacancies that the problem
is a shortage of
of labor and uh and that's and that is
what we need to fix it doesn't stop
women returning from maternity leave
being made redundant i don't want to see
that happen oh correct one in nine sorry
or currently
can you wait in government legislation
can you let us know when you're going to
bring that in
well we'll we'll do everything of course
i'll let you know
uh about that uh but our intention is to
help everybody
coming back from maternity leave to get
into work or back into work as fast as
possible
thank you prime minister thank you
caroline notes
thank you bernard mister can you tell me
what specific initiatives ministers are
bringing forward to build back
in a more feminine and gender-neutral
way
uh caroline we are doing
everything that we can to uh ensure that
uh we have a recovery that is
uh as i was saying just now uh to mr
mckinley
uh that gets uh our our women back into
the workforce i know that they've had
uh particular uh problems uh
making sure that we get uh everybody
back uh
to work in the in in a way that is um
as i say fair to fare across uh both
sexes
um actually uh if if you look at what's
happened with
um uh with
uh furlough uh
i think according to the resolution
foundation uh
52 percent of i further has generally
attracted more
uh more female um uh
uh recipients than the male uh so far
uh which i think is uh which i think is
is positive
and well it's evidence prime minister
that women were more likely to be in
sectors
that were shut down longer what level of
female employment do you regard as
evidence that we have
built back in a more feminine way
well karen we want we want to make sure
that
we have um female
employment rising across the board we'll
have a employment
rising across the board and just to
quote what the uh the resolution
foundation
uh said they they said that the economic
impact of covid
19 has been surprisingly equal for uh
for men and women
and that doesn't mean that there aren't
specific problems like the one
that's just been referred to on
returning from maternity leave that we
must address and we will
but your own ministers won't publish
economic impact assessments
on furlough so we don't know from the
government's own figures
what the impact has been across
different genders
well i i'm quoting from the resolution
foundation
uh republican quoting from from the
economic impact assessments of your own
ministers and the government equalities
office
well the as you as you know caroline uh
all
um all policies must uh
under the public sector equality duty uh
in the equality act
uh be scrutinized for their impact on
uh on uh on different groups but the uh
the the information i have is that the
uh the the gender pay gap
uh is at a record low uh
we have 1.9 million more women in work
than there were
uh in 2010 uh and uh women for instance
on
uh ftse uh 350 boards is up around 50
percent
uh 50 there's a 50 increase in women on
footsie
uh 350 boards in just five years uh
which i think is is quite fast going and
and those are i think
a pretty useful metrics uh caroline
and should policies for recovery be in
the round
or should they be targeted at those who
were most impacted by covid
we want to have a recovery
that looks after everybody in society
uh everyone everywhere and the
the if i think back to 28
and uh that crisis i think that when we
when we came out of it uh i'm not
certain that we did
uh deal with people's sense of injustice
and uh and inequality we have a huge job
to do now
as as a government as a conservative
government to level up and unite across
the whole country
and that is what we're going to do you
can't point at a single policy or
initiative
that is going to help you build back in
a more feminine
and gender neutral way just one
well i i've
i've mentioned already uh what we've
done uh by reducing the gender pay gap
caroline to an all-time low uh if you
look at
uh let's give you an example look at the
look at the foreign office
uh for instance uh we have we now have
female and
which uh which is leading uh
if you want to look at a more feminine
approach uh to tackling climate change
it is our
our diplomats around the world in uh in
washington
in uh in new york uh in
uh in beijing uh their
their female uh uh caroline and and so
many and they are the people they are
the people at the tip of their other
people at the tip of the
of the uk mission uh to build back
better
uh for the world a 40 i think if you
look at our climate change negotiators
caroline a half of them are female
and and they're doing a fantastic
job as i was saying earlier on and they
have succeeded
in building back better for britain and
the world by getting
70 percent of the world's economy uh to
commit to getting to
to net zero uh by 2050. that's a
fantastic
achievement by british women
but you didn't get the financial pledges
from the g7
i think i'm getting the feeling that you
would find fault was almost anything
uh that uh that we did caroline with the
greatest possible respect to you
and we did uh get the get the the
we did get the 100 billion uh and uh we
are
and i think that we will surprise you on
the upside and british
uh women uh in cop and uh represented in
this government as they are
abundantly uh will surprise you on the
upside by
uh by what they achieved to build back
better in a more feminine way
if you can think of a way of saying
build that more feminine in a pithier
way then then you know
send me a postcard well our are so wrong
our sole role is to find fault so that
you can make things
even better prime minister meg hilliar
thank you mr bernard
um prime minister you talk about
building back better and levelling up
what's your message to people who are
living in seriously overcrowded
accommodation who since the time you've
been mayor and prime minister i've seen
toddlers grow into teenagers in that
accommodation who are working but can't
afford the private rents
and can't afford to buy your government
has fueled house purchases
but what support are you going to give
to those people who need
better housing well don't forget that
this government professional
uh you mentioned like my time as as
mayor and i'm i'm glad you do because it
gives me 80 percent affordable
private rent it gives me the opportunity
to point out
uh the paucity of the current
labor mayors prime minister prime
minister i'm actually asking about what
you're doing as a prime minister can i
can i just mention i mentioned it
doesn't mean but
prime minister if you want to talk about
your record as mayor prime minister that
was when you define
affordable housing can i just be if you
could let me finish yeah
you define affordable housing as 80
percent of local private rents
do you know what private rents are this
is the government this is the government
this is the government
that actually just increased local
housing
allowance again uh don't forget in order
to tackle
uh precisely that that doesn't tackle
the overcrowding prime minister
and uh when you talk about supply and i
get i was you
uh talk about the record of the previous
mayor of london and the current mayor of
london that's banned apparently but you
know
it's a relevant consideration uh i built
far more big boss now
far more homes than he did uh but now
across the the uk uh we
had this last year a record number of
housing starts and never let it be
forgotten
uh that the conservatives i think in the
prime minister my point is one year
prime minister
council your own government built more
council homes prime ministers
than labor did you your government
cannot even tell us how many social
housing units
have been built you're fueling a supply
but for purchase which is fine for those
who can purchase but for many people
particularly
in expensive parts of the country like
my constituency cannot
purchase and cannot rent i forget
meg that we built more council homes in
one year than your labour party your
labor government did in 13 years okay
so i won't take any lessons about
building social homes
and i built it it's not enough is it
more in london
than the current mayor uh has done or or
will do
and we will and and by the way i i
disagree with you respectfully
about um people's ambitions for
homeownership i do think social housing
is of massive importance we must build
more social housing
and that's totally right but i think
ultimately lots of people in this
country
uh in their in their twenties thirties
prime minister you're playing against my
words i have nothing against home
ownership but many people
simply can't afford it many people
simply can't afford it
made your point meg thank you very much
prime minister i prefer respectfully as
part of the um discourse um can we move
on to
post-brexit impact and we go to the
chair of the scottish select committee
people shop
and thank you sir and good afternoon
prime minister
since brexit's happened there's just a
whole load of activity around what's
referred to as strengthening the union
what if it becomes clear that scotland
doesn't want the union strengthened
i i'm not at all sure that that's
that's true pete and
you and i have had many exchanges on
this in the past
but i think that uh the
um you know there was a vote in in 2014
i think it was pretty
clear what the people of scotland uh
wanted um it was it was decisive
and uh in terms of the uh of the union
uh you know people just just just look
at it you know in a in a dispassionate
way
uh the the the strength of of our common
institutions
was really palpable during that pandemic
what i'm looking at is
an election that was held less than two
months ago and as you know five minutes
was elected was a majority of um
msps who favored independence for a
nation so i mean that would indicate to
me that there doesn't seem to be such an
appetite for the strength of the union
in fact
quite the opposite so would you just do
this to scotland enemy regardless of
what our
democratic institutions say about this
what would i do what strengthen the
union to whatever that's supposed to be
would you do it just like you imposed
the single the internal market act
on scotland just like you decided that
scotland would be taken at the european
union even though
it was rejected but there were
overwhelming majority people in scotland
just something you could do to us how
are you going to approach the scotland
and scottish government
they just just do things to us no i i
don't think i did but i don't think
it can be bad for all the constituent
parts of the
of the union to have um their
uh their trading relations strengthened
to have uh
their friendship strengthened uh to have
their
means of easy uh communication uh
strengthened uh their the their their
their roots
uh from one part of the union to another
stranger so it seems to me to be
a good thing and something that's pretty
hard to argue against well
just your former senior advisor rather
than charitably
said you were an unthinking unionist who
thinks devolution was a disaster
who would like to reverse it but would
dear try
that's pretty accurate isn't it would
you reverse
if you had the chance no no i was what
do you really feel about demolition
i was i mean i was a massive beneficiary
of devolution dave as as i was just
saying to to make hillier
uh it was it was the uh the labour
government's decision to
uh in the in the in the late 90s uh
to follow the john smith package and and
to devolve
uh that enabled me to become mayor of
london
and uh to and i think it was a great
thing
now what you didn't find when i was
mayor of london you didn't find the
endlessly
uh attacking uh central government and
moaning
about it and you didn't find me
endlessly trying uh to to shuffle off
blame and responsibility
on the central government i took
responsibility
and i may say i think the problem is not
with demolition and the problem is
uh with the party in power
seems to crop up quite a bit because one
you have admitted to
and you've conceded to when you were
speaking to northern tory mps you said
that
this was the devolution was tony blair's
biggest mistake
and again you refer to it as a disaster
you didn't say that didn't you
i i certainly think that the uh
there are disastrous aspects of uh
scottish government scottish as a
scottish national
scottish national party's performance in
delivering
uh education uh in in fighting
crime uh intacting the scourge of drugs
uh i think there have been lamentable
failures
yes i do now the difficult thing for me
as prime minister of the uk
is how to it's and it's a it's a it's a
it's a difficult thing
because i love the whole uk and i wanted
all to
succeed it's very hard uh to mount the
ramparts and say that something is going
wrong
uh in scotland i don't want to do that i
want scotland
uh to be brilliantly governed and it
should be but i just think that the
the snp is not delivering uh as what it
could
but but you're now the minister for the
union
could you maybe list your top three
achievements since you gave yourself
that position i think that
uh the i think you'll be in videos of me
to
to come here i think i think i will i
will i will
i will leave that uh uh it must be to
others
i think i think that um the union is
uh let me give you an example of the
strength of the
of the union uh it was and it was became
obvious to me
um during the pandemic um
the the role of the of the british army
for instance
in uh rolling out not just the the
vacation
achievements about the charity not just
the vaccine but the testing centers
uh and uh i i do think that the
the vaccine rollout can be broadly
counted an achievement of the government
yes i do
uh and uh on the on the i think i would
even go so far said the union played a
massive role in the development of the
of the vaccine let me just and then the
whole testing i thought they've got
medical labor
number two testing uh it was fantastic
to go to glasgow
and see the uh the work of
scientists students in uh in glasgow
testing
uh samples that came from uh from
kent and it was but thanks to the work
of those uh those glasgow scientists
uh that we were able to identify uh the
kent the camera specifically
scotland
us in the independence movement anyway
well i noticed that the conservatives
since you think
conservatives got a bigger share of the
vote than ever before
thank you very much uh mr jenkins and um
it's
come to the west country prime minister
of your holiday this year
and come to devon the sunshine's all
always in endeavor
now with brexit um becomes trade deals
um and we've now gone in principle trade
deal with australia
which we welcome strategically now what
it brings with it is
in the future a hundred thousand tons of
beef so
you know we've got great ruby red beef
being uh
we're here on exmoor we've got great
lambs across the country
and great milk what we need now to do is
to go on a great
drive to export to australia
export all across the world so what
prime minister are you going to put in
place
to help us get a great british brand
and i do say british um and get it
across the world
well uh thank you very very much uh miss
neil mr parish
uh we are doing a massive export drive
for
british for british food and we have
staff in 119 markets who are dedicated
to supporting uk food and drink
and we are opening up so in june uh we
got uh i think thanks to the deals done
by
by liz uh by the secretary of state for
the trade
uh we're now selling poultry to japan
uh for for the first time uh we we
in march of last year we finally broke
down the
barriers to british beef uh going to
america and i know that you take a
lively interest in
uh in in british uh beef neal and you'll
be thrilled to know
uh that one company they called foils
food
uh has already sold uh already sold
three million tons foils have also three
sorry
sorry three million pounds worth three
million tons would be a lot
a lot of people pounds worth three
million pounds worth of beef
uh to to to the united states and
you know where falls the uh the there's
just a
it's the thinning of the wedge uh it's
the it's the beginning i'm sure that i'm
sure that you
and the british farming will find plenty
of other
opportunities around the world yes we
greatly welcome
what we're doing but you see we've got a
counsellor in beijing
and that's about all we have you see
from our embassies and so therefore
you've got you've got the australians
within within 15 locations
across the world and they spend 20
million dollars so
you know in our embassies we need to
have food
councillors to be able to promote our
british food because
if we're going to really get on the
front foot because
trade is not only just about one way
coming into this country
it's going out and if we want to build a
greater environment
for our food we that grass-fed beef has
got to be reared
it's got to be looked after and then
it's going to be sold at a profit
we've got to get that into that those
foreign markets so what are we going to
do to have our embassies
to have these councillors across the
world can you give me a commitment
to do that i can say first of all how
much i love your attitude
and uh your right and your right to to
be optimistic about it scottish beef too
uh by the way pete it's the future um
so what we wanted to do is uh
actually you'll find if as you go around
our embassies
there is always somebody there who knows
what to do but i think what we need to
do is make sure that the
uh the the the agricultural sector
themselves
know where the opportunities are and and
and what we should be doing
i think is uh in a much more crisp way
uh summarizing uh the opportunities
giving them
uh to the food prime minister sorry to
interrupt but that's
what these food counsellors particularly
do in all these countries right they go
back to this
to their country and say this is the way
to get into the market
this is to help the small businesses the
farms everybody else the processors
get out there into china far east
wherever it might be
that's why we need these food cancers so
that's what yes i agree with that i
totally agree with that
uh there should be somebody in every uh
embassy around the world who has that
responsible responsibility but i also
want to do i'm putting 38 million pounds
into uh giving uh
smes the information that they that they
need on their side so
we need we need to we need to join them
up we need to join up
uh the uh british food uh business
you know in all it's amazing diversity
we need to join up
the uh the manufacturers the uh the
entrepreneurs all the people who are
who are making this stuff with our
diplomatic network
prime minister we're in total agreement
but the one thing i haven't got from you
is are you going to put those resources
yes well i've already i've already told
you so we've got the 38 million years
into goes into debts
but it's internationalization within our
embassies we have
those food councils and i'm sorry to
press it because we've been trying to do
this for years
um and we must make sure we do it we
have in 109
markets that's by markets i mean
countries uh we have
a specific staff dedicated to uh
agricultural food and drink and you will
notice what i will
take to you neil uh is i will go back
and i will make sure
uh that uh uh that we have somebody
specifically
devoted to uh increasing
uh food and drink exports and and
somebody who
and what we also need to do is build up
the networks
so that people uh so that the the
business in this country which mainly
sell within this country
start to think about export as well
that's why we're putting the 25 million
uh into uh into export finance for
for food uh and drink but also the 38
million
uh to uh to build up the the net worth
well thank you prime minister i'll take
you up on your offer good i hope you i
hope
i hope to see you you know can we can we
add that topic to the letter you
certainly can
you certainly can this um and can i also
ask uh
your prime minister if you will include
a note
on the figures of expected hospital
admissions
if isolation was ended on the 19th of
july rather than on the 16th of august
i will see what i can do that would be
very helpful thank you
can i just also add one of the post
brexit hangovers where we used to export
musicians and talent across the european
union
uh with great alacrity and this is uh
very severely threatened as you know and
was raised by julian knight at the last
session
and he's asked me to raise it again and
it seems the eu is still digging in
on the question of an eu visa waiver for
touring artists musicians and performers
um in your talks with
chancellor merkel um and i did this with
you by letter before you saw her
did you get an opportunity to raise this
with her well in fact germany
is uh one of the the better uh
countries on this uh on this issue and i
mean
we didn't specifically discuss this at
uh at our recent
uh meeting but the uh
the germans are better than some others
about 17 eu members are
quite good seven are not so uh
are not so good and uh we are working on
it to
uh to sort it out and and we will
now the the the proposal that um
for a total visa uh waiver is obviously
uh an interesting but you'd have to you
have to ask yourself
well what other um professions could you
include in that and it's hard to
uh to see where you would uh where you
would draw the line
and um i you know subverted you
campaigned
uh heroically for taking back control of
our of our borders
uh and for uh coming out of the of the
eu
um we wouldn't want accidentally to uh
to to reverse that in this particular
case by by gradual erosion of uh of our
of our freedom
so um we are making a great deal of
progress and i
appreciate how how frustrating it is um
and i i know that uh sir elton john
is uh in talks with uh with uh
other eu partners about how does how to
speed this up uh but
i feel it's very much in their interests
uh this is something that
uh in all our societies benefit from
massively and i hope that it will be
uh speedily resolved but i think i would
have enjoyed asking chancellor merkel
who wants
to stop cultural exchange which was one
of the objectives of her visit
to the european commission because we we
would we would not
stop visiting artists coming to our own
country but we are losing people from
london
permanently they're going to take up
residence in other european countries
with
european citizenship because they can't
operate
they can't pursue their careers by
staying
by saying in london well i i hope that
we're not and
the evidence doesn't seem to support the
view that we're losing
all eu nationals uh because
after all as you would have noticed it's
not about eu nationals it's about
british citizens taking up citizenship
in other countries
because their career opportunities are
so limited compared to what they were
it's a very serious problem prime
minister i hope you'll encourage all
frost
i will and i know that you're you're a
distinguished and famous
uh chorister uh sir bernard uh and i
hope that your own
uh uh your gigs uh have not been in
in any way restricted as a result of
this so far and i i will make sure that
we we
do whatever we can i've been resting for
some time um
i'm now going to move on to simon hall
chairman of northern ireland committee
thank you chairman good afternoon prime
minister prime minister i think
you and i will agree that there is
nothing in the northern ireland protocol
which in any way uh affects negatively
in the constitutional integrity of our
united kingdom now while you and i
might see that and understand it there's
a
there's a growing group of people who
live in northern ireland you'll be aware
of this who are very concerned
that the protocol is in some way a
stepping stone to a
a border pole and a reunification
referendum
and the like in a number of evidence
sessions that we've had recently
in the committee it's become very clear
that they want to hear
in the clearest possible terms from you
as prime minister
your support for northern ireland is
part of the uk
its continuation as part of the uk
whilst it wishes to be so and the
determination to maintain
the union of great britain and northern
ireland could i invite you to do that
this afternoon
you certainly can simon i i've actually
just been called an unthinking
uh unionist by my friends
and uh i don't think i'm an um i don't i
don't think i'm an unthinking unionist i
think i'm a passionate
uh unionist i i believe in uh our
country
and uh the way it works in the uh
the four nations uh coming together i
think it's a it's a fantastic
fantastically powerful thing it's it's
the greatest uh
global advertisement uh for for
cooperation and working together
it's it's it is uh a wonderful thing and
we want to
uh to to strengthen it not in an
assertive
or interfering way but we want we want
to we want to strengthen it
and uh that there is simon absolutely
no threat to northern ireland's place
within the united kingdom and there
should
not be that let me let me use
measurements there should not be
uh from the protocol and it it's clear
in article six
two of the protocol uh for instance uh
that
uh all sides are asked to use their best
endeavors uh to ensure that there is
uh free trade uh a seamless uh movement
between great britain
uh and northern ireland it's clear that
uh
uh northern ireland is a part of the
sovereign territory of the
of the united kingdom uh that's all
clear from the protocol
the unfortunate uh thing is that
um the protocol is being applied
currently
in a way that causes uh some of the
anxieties
to which you've just referred and so
what we have
i want you to come on to that yes
um thank you for the clarity of the
first part of the answer that's
appreciated i know it will be heard
uh across northern this afternoon uh the
joint committee
was clearly set up because it was known
that the protocol at the start wasn't
going to be perfect that they were going
to be issues that would need to be
addressed
and that is best done through a position
of mutual political
trust business we keep hearing in the
committee will abide by whatever rules
it is that these politicians require
them to abide by as long as there is
certainty
and clarity and stability in the
delivery of those
what um value if you will
would you put on that issue of political
trust
in the workings of the joint committee
with
a bit of give and take which i know is
not always um
palatable to some but with a bit of give
and take on both sides
to make sure that the protocol is
working as well as it possibly can
so that those benefits of one foot in
both markets
which is a unique selling point for
northern ireland can be maximized
i think you're spot on uh sign i think
that that is
that is what is needed i think what is
needed now is goodwill and imagination
but there are some very serious problems
and
the you know the you know the statistics
of all the checks that are currently
conducted around the whole perimeter of
the
of the eu for customs and other purposes
twenty percent
uh are taking place uh in northern
ireland uh although
i think ireland desert the island of
ireland has only uh point five percent
of
uh of the eu's uh population uh or
thereabouts
uh you've got um a very difficult
situation in which
vital drugs have not been able to be
moved from great britain
to northern ireland 30 drugs including
cancer drugs
i think about 200 companies have stopped
shipping stuff
uh there's been uh impediments to
uh to the movement of guide dogs of
parcels of potted plants of tractor
parts
um i think i'm right in saying that uh
asda um is not actually
uh they don't actually have asda shops
in uh
the uh republic of ireland and yet
as the goods coming into uh into
into northern ireland uh have all to be
checked
and uh uh only only yesterday
uh there were very serious
representations
uh from the jewish community in northern
ireland uh who pointed out that
uh because of the uh the problem with uh
with the food sector uh it was becoming
difficult to
for them to to have uh timely access or
any access
to kosher food and they're talking now
about
an exodus from from northern ireland by
the
uh by the jewish community now clearly
uh we want to do everything we can
to avoid that and to sort it out but
it's going to take um
our friends in the in the joint
committee to make uh some movement and
and to make that movement pretty fast
um what movement would you envisage the
uk government making
as it you know to coin the phrase it
takes two to tango
uh i think we've been very clear that
uh we are implementing the protocol the
uk is a faithful
uh obedient uh servant of the law
the things that i have described are a
direct result
of this of what uk officials
are doing in upholding the law
and obeying uh the eu jurisdiction
uh the problem is that i i think and i
think any impartial listener
of this conversation uh i think that the
the way the eu is is trying to implement
the the protocol is currently grossly
disproportionate and unnecessary
can i could i just ask you for a final
question which is
um could you say a little about what you
think the strength is
of our relationship with regards to the
republic uh
violent at the current time and where
you will
see it move to how you would like to see
it
i think i think that's a really terrific
question and
i think the sooner we can put this
problem to behind us
the better because the relations between
london and dublin
underlying this uh issue are truly
fantastic
and uh the um uh the
relations we have uh both with michael
martin
uh and indeed as we had with uh uh his
predecessor
uh leah vraka uh are very very
progressive there are things we want
to do we want to get on and do them
there are there are things where the the
uk
and ireland can work together on uh
talking about
uh connectivity but as i was with with
pete uh on on north south connectivity
uh in the island of ireland on what we
can do east west
uh uh what we can do over the border uh
working together in
uh in the londonderry area there is a
huge amount that we want to get on
and do together uh to to strengthen
our friendship and partnership don't
forget the the the uk's economic
uh relations with ireland are colossal i
mean they're they they remain
uh one of our biggest uh our biggest
export markets our biggest trading
partners and friends
testing your patients by going over time
and that's very very generous but this
is the final set of questions on the
same topic from
sir bill cash i'm sure that your our
viewers may be switching over to the
football i mean i i
i didn't know that we're able to compete
much longer so prime minister
do you agree that one of the primary
reasons for our signing the northern
ireland protocol
was to preserve the belfast good friday
agreement
and that the mutual obligations in the
protocol
must be seen through that focus which we
do
but unfortunately the eu seems to ignore
although i have to admit they have made
one sensible decision on the question of
children meets
but on the other hand we need many more
sensible decisions of that kind
and do you agree that we need them soon
and in the immediate future
yes we we do seville and
on chill meets by the way just going
back to what i was saying to simon
uh that is very far from fixed all we
have is a stay of execution there
and this is what uh the the jewish
community was saying
uh in in new orleans they they
they're facing a real real problem
unless we can
unless we can sort this out um and
i agree totally with your
characterization of the of the problem
we can the the we understand
the vital importance of protecting uh
free movement north south
and protecting uh the the
making sure that there should be no hard
border within the island of ireland
that's the whole point
and and we've done that and it's been a
massive effort by the uk state
what we agreed was that to make that
happen
in a reasonable way we would undertake
to do certain checks on stuff that could
circulate
in theory uh in in
ireland itself uh on after arrival in
northern ireland that's what we
undertook to do as an act of enabling
this
to look after the uh eu single market to
which is what they wanted us to do
we also agreed uh unfortunately that the
eu could have
uh a say in how this was done and that
has been the problem
and they've been implementing the
protocol in a way that
is producing the the types of anomalies
that i've been describing and we need to
we need to fix it so given the unique
circumstances
as the protocols state of the northern
ireland situation which is both
deeply historical and deeply political
with
a marching season coming out and all the
rest of it do you agree that we must
also focus on stability
trade peace and community relationships
in northern ireland without in any way
apologizing
to pick up on what simon was saying
earlier on are insisting
on the constitutional integrity of
northern ireland
um as an invaluable part of the united
kingdom
absolutely and that's after what it says
in the protocol so
so so i think that is a very fair point
um i think what we all need to do
is uh you know work rapidly on some
uh solutions uh fix this thing uh fast
um i think it will take some uh some
effort but we we really can't exclude
uh anything we've got uh any actions
that the uk government may need
to take as i've said many times to to
protect what it what it says in the
protocol
the east-west dimension of the belfast a
good friday
agreement which is which is you know
equally important as
the north south dimension clearly and uh
to to protect the the territorial
integrity
of the uk and how often do we have to
say to them it's in your and our mutual
interests
to be flexible about this arrangement
because actually it may be written down
in a certain fashion but
actually the truth is you want to get
this right you have to have a degree of
mutual cooperation and flexibility
yeah i think that's right and uh we will
the the noble
uh lord frost uh will continue to to
make that point with his
uh customer very clear diplomatic uh
force
and ultimately couldn't we recognize
that article 13
8 of the protocol actually does pressage
the possibility
of superior arrangements to the protocol
alternative arrangements he does and uh
that
if that is going to be protecting the
good friday agreement more effectively
and treating the two communities with
more parity
and fairness that would be the right way
forward completely right
suburban and it cannot be beyond the
width of man as i think
uh you and i and others have been saying
for at least five years
uh for such the technology uh to
uh come to our aid and sort it out well
prime minister thank you very much
you've been very patient
20 minutes i'm very grateful to you
won't detain you a moment
at longer order order thank you
and there you have it boris johnson
appearing in front of
the liaison committee um quite a long
afternoon for the prime minister and
obviously
following um pmq's earlier
it's a committee made up of the chairs
of 32 select committees
and the chair of the joint committee on
human rights
let's bring in our deputy political
editor now sam coats he was obviously
watching that with us
joins us live from westminster a wide
range of topics covered during the
course of the afternoon sam uh what are
your main takeaways
well at times it was quite a touchy
session with boris johnson clashing with
a number of mps not only labour
like chris bryant who was pressing him
on whether or not he sacked matt hancock
boris johnson referred back to his
answer saying he saw the allegations
about him
uh and his aid on friday and he was gone
on saturday and meg hilliar the chair
of the public accounts committee they
clashed uh over social housing and the
contrasting
records the conservative party uh when
boris johnson was mayor of london
and uh now with her complaining that not
enough uh detail was being given by
government about that but also boris
johnson clashed with conservatives like
caroline
uh no she was also asking about uh the
impact of uh foreign aid cuts on uh
women and whether or not those would
uh help that group but uh he got quite
touchy with her as well
uh in the end i thought there were a
number of quite start
um stark uh revelations in this select
committee uh
particularly i thought on the issue of
net zero now this matters at the moment
not only because britain is hosting the
cop climate change summit later in the
year but we are actually expecting
announcements maybe as soon as next week
with critical meetings going on inside
government
this week about what the government's
policy should be in order to ensure that
britain comes
uh reduces carbon emissions it brings uh
those down to uh to net zero and
basically boris johnson thinking
appeared to be a good deal of caution
about any move
that would put additional burdens on
consumers
so for instance boris johnson was
challenged in this committee about the
fact that only about 35
000 or so heat pumps have been installed
and there are still 25 million fossil
fuel
boilers in people's homes how on earth
are you going to deal with that need for
transition if you're going to get to net
zero
boris johnson simply said look uh the
problem here is that heat boilers cost
10 000 pounds a pop that's too much we
can't expect people
uh to pay for that then there was the
other big area that the government has
to tackle when it comes to fossil fuels
and that's
petrol and diesel cars boris johnson was
asked about that
and he was asked and he basically said
well the important thing here uh is that
as the number of petrol and diesel cars
goes down and electric
cars replace them and the exchequer gets
less money as a result of
uh the tax that you would get uh that
they would charge on petrol and diesel
uh disappearing you can't then raise the
amount of tax that drivers
of fossil fuel cars fueled by cars
fueled by fossil fuels
have to pay to fill the gap so he's very
concerned about consumer costs which i
suspect is a message
that conservative mps want to hear but
it's not necessarily
giving us any glimpse of what the answer
is inside government suggesting that
these
uh issues are very uh difficult couple
other things
of note in that select committee hearing
on schools a very clear hint from boris
johnson
that there could be more to come there
will be more to come uh on helping
peoples who've missed out because of
coronavirus even suggesting they might
return to the issue
of lengthening the school day initially
the evidence uh for even from his own
advisors wasn't strong enough he
suggested
uh but he seemed to hint that he might
come back to that
uh and he also hinted that there could
be an inquiry into the subject of an
afghan of afghanistan and that
20-year conflict uh boris johnson's
going to himself give a statement to the
house of commons tomorrow
on that it could seem from the way he
was talking about it
even be an inquiry into how that worked
he talked about the need uh
to learn uh lessons uh and then finally
there's a lot of work going on in
government at the moment about the eu
northern ireland
protocol the agreement that governs how
sits in that special status uh between
uh
great britain as part of the united
kingdom but also with stronger links to
the european union than elsewhere in
order to stop there being a hard border
between northern ireland and republic
and boris johnson basically suggested
that we needed to go back to some of
these
the solutions uh that were talked about
all the way through the brexit debate
involving technology repeatedly ruled
out
uh by the european union but that
technology might enable us to have a
soft border
between the republic and northern
ireland but also less of those checks
that are causing problems in northern
ireland
uh between northern ireland and great
britain so quite a lot to chew on at
times quite
testy but boris johnson giving us a
glimpse into one of the live subjects
uh inside government right now and how
he is thinking about them
okay sam thank you so much well while
boris johnson faced those questions the
latest covert data was released
and they've been 32 548
new cases that's the highest daily
figure since january
33 more deaths have been reported